we start in India and the iconic Harbour
Bridge in Kolkata that became the scene
of tragedy a dangerous underwater escape
that went horribly wrong
Indian stuntman John Cho Lahiri who
called himself the wizard Mandrake said
he wanted to revive interest in magic by
replicating a Houdini inspired trick
under the bridge near Kolkata Lahiri was
tied up with a heavy rope and steel
chains secured by six locks he was then
lowered by crane into the Hooghly River
after ten minutes he still hadn't
realized
to the horror of onlookers which
included members of his family rescue
teams were mobilized and yesterday they
found John Cho Lahiri's body still in
Chains washed up a kilometer from where
he entered the water
this wasn't Larry's first underwater
stunt and he knew the risks Ebert see
him in a turbulent River it will be very
hard to open the knots and locks but I
will open them and if I do that it's
magic if not then it's tragic
prophetic words almost did a blue
correspondent Sonia FeliCa is standing
by for us in Delhi Sonia good to see you
what do we know about the details of
this case well British police in the
state of West Bengal say Chanchala he
had indeed taken permission from the
authorities in this case both the
Calcutta police as well as the Dutch
authorities in order to do this stunt
but they say that in his permission
letter he really didn't say that he was
planning to jump into the water but
rather the stunt would be carried out on
a boat or a vessel another police
official has been quoted as saying that
you know he did mention the letter very
vaguely that there was an extra act but
he didn't really spell out what that was
going to be another report here in an
Indian newspaper suggests that Lahiri
also wore rather heavy and cumbersome
clothing and guards when he was lowered
into the water so that would have made
it very difficult to swim in the strong
current of the holy river but there's
also reports coming out Sonia that this
wasn't the first time he was attempting
this stunt
that's right parish it really wasn't the
first time but we have to also remember
that Chandra Lahiri's career really
seems to have you know been marked by a
series of hits and misses you know for
example just before this act Lahiri told
a reporter that he had successfully
carried out this stunt at the exact same
spot 21 years ago yet in 2013
Lahiri had attempted the same stunt near
the Hooghly River and apparently that
had gone wrong he was apparently
assaulted by a crowd of onlookers who
first treated because they saw him
escape from a locked cage via a door
that was clearly visible he was
apparently punched and beaten his
trademark you know flowing golden brown
wig was pulled off and tenures near
earlier Lahiri had also declared that he
planned to you know walk the walk on the
river Hooghly but that also apparently
misfired and here to abandon that effort
tell us about the rules and regulations
in place what about the official term
here what do magicians need to follow
certain procedures to ensure that their
stunts are ultimately safe
well bearish to the best my knowledge I
haven't really come across any rules or
regulations governing these kinds of
stunts and that is I think we have to
remember that that magic or or magicians
like Lahiri are really a part of a
vanishing breed you know magic is losing
its popularity in India partially thanks
to the Internet which is really kind of
promising to make a magician out of
everyone and traditionally you know we
have to remember most of India's
magicians have been street performers
you know whether it's jugglers snake
charmers tightrope walkers and these
people have really been pushed out of
India by a series of laws against saved
child labor or animal cruelty they've
been pushed to the margins when they do
perform it's in small villages and those
those performances are often really not
subject to any any safety procedures
sonofa Anika reporting for us from Delhi
thank you very much for that